audiencia pública esperada por millones
de estadounidenses tras meses de
investigación estas revelaciones lastran
un poco más a Donald Trump para los
miembros de la comisión no hay duda el
expresidente estadounidense no tenía
intención de aceptar su derrota en las
elecciones presidenciales
hoy sabemos más sobre las intenciones
del presidente Trump en la noche
electoral según las pruebas su falso
discurso de Victoria se preparó con
mucho antelación Incluso antes de que se
contaran los votos fue un plan
premeditado por el presidente reclamar
la victoria independientemente de los
resultados reales había planeado no
dejar el cargo incluso antes del día de
las elecciones
y para respaldar sus palabras la
demócratas del ofgreen se apoya en
varias grabaciones difundidas este
jueves durante la audiencia en una de
ellas escuchamos Alex asesor estratégico
de Donald Trump
hablaba con sus socios el 31 de octubre
de 2020 tres días de las elecciones
presidenciales lo que va a hacer Trump
es declararse ganador se va a declarar
ganador Pero eso no significa que vaya a
ganar solo va a decir que ganó otra
revelación sobre una orden supuestamente
dada por Donald Trump una semana después
de las elecciones
el presidente Trump ordenó una gran
retirada de las tropas estadounidenses
lo hizo sin tener en cuenta las
consecuencias que esto Podría tener en
los frágiles gobiernos que están en
primera línea de la lucha contra los
terroristas del estado islámico y de
alqaeda Sabiendo perfectamente que iba a
dejar el cargo actuó inmediatamente y
firmó esta orden el 11 de noviembre de
está retirada se refería a las tropas
desplegadas en Afganistán y somalia para
el republicano electo Adam kissinger
está orden emitida por Donald Trump es
la prueba de que sabía que tendría que
dejar el cargo y según varios
testimonios en contra de lo que declaró
públicamente el ex presidente admitió
varias veces delante de su entorno que
efectivamente
subtítulo las elecciones esto plantea la
cuestión de si esta supuestas mentiras
de Donald Trump Podrían haber provocado
el asalto al Capitolio y la muerte de
cinco personas en cualquier caso el ex
jefe de estado ha sido citado por la
comisión de investigación parlamentaria